hi my name is Christina waters and I am
the CEO and founder of rare science I am
also the senior vice president and
general manager of the global rare
disease program at wujin Xcode I was
speaking today about accelerating cures
for rare childhood diseases by building
global communities and inducible
pluripotent stem cell collections
through my nonprofit rare science rare
science is a nonprofit research
organization with the mission to
accelerate finding more immediate
therapies for kids around the world with
rare disease and it is a honor and I
thank the organizers for allowing me to
be a part of 24hours stem cell day
the challenges of rare disease even
though rare disease is fundamentally
rare it actually affects 300 to 400
million people around the world more
than half of these affected are children
so that means that we're looking at an
estimated 200 million kids around the
world that have rare diseases these
patient populations are very small and
we've identified about 8,000 different
rare diseases currently rare diseases
are responsible for 35% of the deaths
within the first year of life and from
this group 30% of these children's will
die before their fifth birthday and this
is at odds with the current drug
development process as it takes an
average of 14 years and two billion
dollars to develop a new therapeutic so
we need to find another solution to
address the urgency that is needed for
kids with rare disease the challenge is
also that we only have fda-approved
treatments for about 5% of the different
rare diseases that have been identified
many of these rare diseases look the
same and so it's very hard to diagnose
them on average it takes seven years in
the US and five years in the UK to for a
correct diagnosis and during this time
these kids could be misdiagnosed two to
three times and see four different
physicians and specialists and during
this time their disease is actually
progressing
so in the rare disease patient journey
it's very different than what we're
doing in rare research and development
which also causes some challenges from
the patient's side we're looking at
parents that have an urgency to find a
diagnosis for their child they need
access to information they're trying to
understand if there are available
therapies that could be used for their
child force or improving quality of care
and even a cure where do they go for
support and guidance and then also
access to these therapies even if they
are available is difficult and then also
the cost of these rare disease therapies
are very expensive and then on the other
side we have research and development
where they're trying to understand how
to get access to patients and bio
samples that are scattered around the
world in addition to the data that is
also located in various places around
the globe these datasets are really
small it's very hard to get statistical
significance on understanding the
biology the causal underpinnings of
these diseases the research and clinical
strategies are not often coordinated and
clinical trials in the regulatory
process even though we're making great
headway aren't always adopted for the
use of a clinical trial that could help
with such a small patient population and
also there's the challenges to access
the funding
you
so even though the cost of DNA
sequencing is going down still we don't
have a lot of access or patient families
don't have a lot of access to getting
their child sequenced when they are
going into the hospital with some type
of unknown cause so we have also an
understanding that currently 30 percent
of the time do we actually under a known
gene or gene variant that's causal and
as I had mentioned before even if we do
identify the genetic etiology of these
rare diseases there's only 5% of the
time there's a therapy that's available
so even with identification of a causal
gene the other complication is that we
don't always understand how the gene or
the gene variants are working in concert
with other gene mutations in the body
and how they're changing the biology
that actually leads to clinical
phenotypes that we can treat
so on the next slide it's very busy but
I wanted to illustrate from the top down
and the bottom up the importance of
being able to translate the
understanding of gene function and
integrating it into the phenotypes that
we see so from the top down in this
example of Neurology we have a lot of
different diseases that look the same
they have names like fragile X autism
send gap and ADC why five of these
different diseases rare diseases
actually have developmental delay but
only fragile X autism and Sen gap show
cognitive delay and have parts some of
these kids have epilepsy eighty cy5 on
on the other hand is a motion disorder
and oftentimes misdiagnosis cerebral
palsy but as you can see in the in the
boxes below
under tissue specificity and expression
of the protein you can see there that
the the expression of these genes and
the proteins that are associated to
these diseases are expressed differently
in different tissue types and so it's so
important to also again go from the
bottom up sequencing understanding what
genes are actually have mutation what
are the molecular pathways that are
involved and then again looking at what
tissues could potentially be affected
and have a changed biology
so the value of inducible pluripotent
stem cell is incredible in the way that
we can utilize them to do a couple of
different things for rare disease on the
right-hand side of this slide you'll see
that and we've often talked about how
currently in the news we're thinking
about how we can use stem cells as a
therapy itself that are derived from the
patients that are sick on the left hand
side of this slide it also shows how the
inducible pluripotent stem cells can be
used for disease modeling so we can
actually take tissue from a patient
create these inducible pluripotent stem
cells and then under start looking at
the function of these stem cells once
they're derived into the tissue of
question there's the possibility of
building functional assays and from
those functional assays there is a hope
that we might be able to even repurpose
currently approved drug or even identify
new molecular targets for new drug
development programs for rare disease
so I wanted to share an example of one
of the rare Sciences first projects and
how it works working directly with
patients families and how we're hoping
to understand the biology of the ADC why
five gene so in the middle of the
picture I wanted to introduce the
Grossman's Steve and Gaye and Lily their
daughter who I met at a patient advocacy
[Music]
organization and conference and Lily
their daughter had been misdiagnosed for
some time with cerebral palsy however
she did get sequenced and they
identified that the gene mutation was in
eighty cy5 the challenge was is that
nobody understood how eighty eighty cy5
gene contributed to such a severe motion
disorder and they also felt they were
the only one in the world that had this
gene mutation and so what we did was
work with ADC y5 org an organization
that was co-founded by both gay and
Steve and identified families on the
right-hand side of the slide that also
had children that had eighty cy5 the
mutation what we found was that there
was a huge difference in the way that
this gene affected the kid there were
kids that were very severe and empowered
chairs to seeing some of the kids that
actually played soccer but they all had
this mutation in the gene so how do we
start understanding again what is the
biology that's causing these diseases
how do we validate which variants or
which mutations actually cause severity
how do we also identify the downstream
biology or pathways that could be
druggable that could lead to a potential
therapy to help these kids
so what we did know about eighty cy5
pathophysiology is that it encode
encodes a regulatory a regulating
synthesis of cyclic a and P and so this
family which is there's ten different
forms of of ADC why this number five is
highly expressed in a striatal tissue of
the brain which is known to be
responsible for motion and then also in
the myocardium but again there was no
understanding how the gene mutation
resulted into the clinical phenotype as
seen in the picture prior we saw a wide
spectrum of observable traits and
different severity we also had an
understanding at the very early on with
some of the great work that had been
done by other scientists in this space
that there was some mosaicism different
cells expressing this mutation than
others but what we did identify was that
all of the kids that had a mutation in
the ADC y-5 gene had a mutation in the
cytosol ik regions of the protein so it
absolutely seemed to have some type of
an effect on cyclic AMP II
so what we wanted to do was actually
start understanding again could we
create a stem cell program and create
stem cells and hopefully dopaminergic
neurons to actually study the biology
that was related to the motion disorder
so what we did was we worked on doing
patient outreach finding families around
the world that wanted to participate we
did an IRB consent approved consent for
these families we also created an
18-page medical history survey
understanding the phenotype of each of
these kids what drugs that they are
therapies they were responding to how
severe they were and again released to
start understanding what was the
connection between the variant and the
actual phenotype that we were seeing at
the bottom of the left-hand side that
graph we actually identified five to
seven different variants but again they
were in all in the cytosolic loop of the
protein and then the the world map
actually showed all of the families that
participated which was five countries
across the world and ten different
families and greater than 50 different
bio samples that we brought back to be
able to start building the stem-cell
collection
so you can imagine this is quite an
undertaking and a lot of great people
were involved my nonprofit rare science
is a completely volunteer organization
and we work with all of these great
companies that helped us with different
expertise to be able to build this
stem-cell collection so that we can
lower the barrier for researchers around
the world to start again understanding
what the biology was that was causing
what we saw as this clinical phenotype
SERM was instrumental at the California
Institute of regenerative medicine which
was funded by state voters in California
by proposition 71 that authorized 3
billion dollars of funding that went
towards building out stem-cell
collections we were one of the first
rare disease stem-cell collections that
have been built through this effort so
as you can see we had been working with
SERM cellular dynamics also Coryell for
banking
Thermo Fisher Scientific was very
helpful in organizing introductions and
reagents to working with aspire IRB for
our consent for vials BD we also work
with hospitals around the world to help
us collect the samples from the patients
that we're going to be sent back to
cellular dynamics and also for
processing of the stem cells that we
were making
so what we can do now to understand rare
disease and potentially have this be a
model for many of the other rare
diseases that we understand what maybe
the gene is but not understanding the
biology we hope that this can
demonstrate and model many other
opportunities and we can scale this
concept but now that we have the stem
cells made from all of these different
families not only the affected child but
also normal siblings and parents we're
able to now start differentiating into
dopaminergic neurons and other tissues
that eighty cy5 is highly expressed to
really start understanding that biology
we can compare the differentiated tissue
of the different variants of the
different kids to see if there is a
connection between the variants and also
the severity of the disease we can also
use CRISPR to revert the mutations back
to normal in quotes so that we can
validate that this actual mutation is
causal to the biology that we're seeing
and then also identify whether there's
other contributing genes or mutations in
that one individual genome in addition
as I mentioned we had a lot of the kids
mosaic and for some of this collection
we were lucky enough to be able to
create clones that have the mutation of
a DC Y 5 and also a clone that doesn't
so these individuals can serve as their
own control and understanding how those
different tissues are functioning
differently
we can also create functional assays to
test therapies
directly using the individuals tissue
and we can also identify hopefully new
molecular targets downstream that are
affecting again the biology and what's
also now so fascinating is that we're
not only able to start building out
different tissue types especially for
that are important for ad cy5 like the
cardiomyocytes and the dopaminergic
neurons but we have also the potential
of building and growing organoids and
hopefully we'll be able to look at many
brains to be able to start understanding
how this could potentially be this
mutation affecting development and also
adult function within a three
dimensional oregon
so what we're currently working on right
now and again this is in partnership and
collaboration with many different groups
and this is how we again hope to scale
our program at rare science and offer
this to more rare disease families is
that the University of Lubeck came
forward and after we started building
our clones they offered sequencing to
ensure that we had did we really did
capture the mutation and what that was
we also have been again making these we
will expand these cells to p10 and make
them available for collaboration for
scientists around the world to be able
to start looking and identifying you
know the biology and answering different
questions that might be important we
also through the University of Humboldt
State we have graduate students that are
already starting to look at the role of
cyclic GMP and the dopaminergic neurons
and not only during differentiation or
after differentiation but before seeing
if there's any difference in the
populations that occur with and without
cyclic E&P and we also we had some
students from Amy sprawls lab at
Humboldt
come down and also spend time with Jean
Loring at Scripps to start understanding
how these different mutations are
responsible for different phenotypic
characterization of the different
dopaminergic neurons that were created
so you may be wondering how we actually
find these families and so currently how
we want to scale and build our program
is with the 1,000 different rare
diseases that we're currently working
with we have reached 5,000 kids and this
is across 50 countries and we actually
do this in a very unique way and that is
as I was saying at the very beginning
these kids are scattered around the
world
there's islands of data how do you bring
people together and we do this through
our unique program which is the rare
bear program where we have people make
one-of-a-kind bears for one-of-a-kind
kids around the world and we use social
media to be able to explain and describe
what these diseases are because again a
lot of these kids are misdiagnosed the
rare bear army is consisting of about
5,000 members currently across 12
countries every state in the u.s. we
have the crafts companies actually
helping us sponsor the making of these
bears which the community coins as bear
skins the bear skins come back to San
Diego California and we work with
philanthropic fraternities the Girl
Scouts of America Boy Scouts
biotech and pharma and you can see we've
had a lot of sewing and stuff ends of
these bear skins right here in Carlsbad
California with thermo Fisher and many
of the other companies in our community
so again we've really brought a a
grassroots community together and made
everybody instrumental in identifying
kids around the world with these rare
diseases to help us understand what's
different and what's similar and from
that we will be able to continue to
start characterizing and seeding new
research with the hope to be able to
understand the biology and build a
faster accelerated way through inducible
pluripotent stem cell collections
new therapy that will help these kids
so as a takeaway
um you know as we start really thinking
about how sequencing is no longer really
the challenge we need to eliminate the
barrier of access to sequencing to all
families that need it the challenge of
rare and common disease will not be the
interpretation and validate the
sequencing of the DNA but the challenge
will be the interpretation and
validation of causal genes new ones that
70% that we still don't understand why
these kids are sick how do we validate
these variants and then and this can be
potentially overcome by using the IPSC
cell lines rare disease and new
technology such as the IPS II can reveal
again new biology and pathways that are
masked by complexities of common disease
empowering rare disease patient families
with tools to build global communities
and drive research to the clinic will
impact global health and then we can
leverage what we learn from one small
rare disease to diseases of similar
biology including common disease and I
believe that the best healthcare is the
most cost effective and that's how if we
can marry the technologies that are
available out there by accelerating
identifying the biology and helping
these kids in the more immediate before
their disease progresses we help
everyone and then lastly I leave you
that we can never underestimate the
power of the sharing economy of good and
what we can all do together through
volunteering and also uniting all of our
expertise in a new way and new pathways
to help kids with rare disease thank you
again for letting me be a part of this
great day
and I leave you with our contact
information if you would like to reach
out to volunteer or learn more about our
program you can email me at seawaters at
rare science org for volunteering info
at rare science org and our website you
can reach us at WWDC NC org if you would
like to see the pictures of the bears
and the kids they've been gifted to you
can also see that at the rare bear kid
gallery on our website thank you again